[Musique]
avant l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre les militants écologistes de
greenpeace ont levé le camp ce soir
toute la journée ils ont bloqué une
raffinerie du groupe américain exxon
mobil près du havre une action pour
dénoncer la politique des états unis en
matière d'environnement
marie-pierre court tellement
les tigres de greenpeace rentrer leurs
griffes
les militants choisissent un départ
volontaire plutôt qu'une confrontation
avec les forces de l'ordre quelques
minutes auparavant le tribunal des
référés du havre a rendu son injonction
l'organisation écologiste doit quitter
les lieux sous peine d'une amende de
30000 euros par jour sans une nouvelle
fois et nous ont pas répondu sur nos
questions et amy ordonne de quitter les
lieux sous peine d'une amende
considérable donc c'est une fois de plus
les dollars contre le climat les
questions musclée de greenpeace concerne
les liens entre le groupe pétrolier
exxon et sow et le président des états
unis la soixantaine de militants qui a
envahi l'entrée de la raffinerie ce
matin en veut à george bush d'avoir
refusé de signer le protocole de kyoto
sur le réchauffement de la planète
une piste protestent aujourd'hui pour
dénoncer esso exxon mobil comme l'ennemi
climatique numéro un la pire des
compagnies pétrolières qui depuis dix
ans a tout tenté pour interférer avec
les négociations internationales de
protection du climat nous nous voulons
aussi signaler que esso a été la
compagnie pétrolière qui a arrosé
littéralement la campagne électorale de
bouche et en retour celui ci une fois
élu a rejeté le protocole de kyoto en
bloc
en marge du débat politique une autre
polémique agite ce soir la normandie la
raffinerie est un site industriel classé
seveso 2 situé dans une zone maritime
interdites d'accès 1800 salariés ont été
bloqués par l'occupation nous avons été
amenés par exemple a stoppé un certain
nombre de nos opérations par exemple aux
appontements
le président bush arrive dimanche en
france et les militants de greenpeace
ont bien l'intention de se rappeler à
son bon goût à son mauvais souvenirs à
l'occasion de cette visite officielle
[Musique]